لماذا لم تتبنى قمه فيلنيوس دعوه واضحه
وصريحه لعضويه اوكرانيا في الحلف
اء يوم
اوكرانيا في المستقبل
قويه جديده من اطعمه السياسيه والعملي في
اوكرانيا كما قال الرئيس
انضمام عباره الى
حرب
ليس ممكن ولكننا نركز على دعم اوكرانيا
احتاج الامر هل هل السبب هو ان اوكرانيا
فعليا لم تستوفي الشروط في حرب ام ان
النيتو والولايات المتحده والغرب بشكل عام
يخشى حقيقه من مواجهه عسكريه مع روسيا
هناك مستقبل
لاوكرانيا سمعته هناك بعض
الاصطنا المتبقيه اللازمه ولكن راينا تقدم
مهم من جنب الاوكراني حتى
ما نوعيه التقدم الذي حققته اوكرانيا في
هذا
التقدم من حيث الاسقاط اللازمه على المسار
العضويات في الناتو الان تركز الحكومه
الامريكيه على الدعم اوكرانيا
العام لخلف الناتو قال بان المهمه الاكثر
الحاحا هي الضمان امداد اوكرانيا باسلحه
كافيه لكن الكثير من المراقبين يران يرون
بانه فعليا على ارض الواقع لا يتم امداد
اوكرانيا بكل ما هو مطلوب خصوصا في ظل
تفوق جوي كبير روسي لم يمكن الاوكران من
احراز اي تقدم
يشار اليه خلال الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد حتى
ونحن
نفعل كل ما نستطيع
دعم اوكرانيا من المتوقع ان ستكون هناك
خانات جديده في الايام المقبله حول ادعم
لاوكرانيا ما هي طبيعه هذه الضمانات الان
التي يقدمها الحلف الضمانات طويله الامد
لاوكرانيا التي تمكنهم بالفعل او تمكن
الاوكرانيين من مواجهه اي اعتداء محتمل
روسي في المستقبل
اترك الاجابه على هذا السؤال بماسولين في
صنعته من وجهه نظر من وجهه ماذا ستقدم
واشنطن في هذا الاطار لا اريد ان استبق
موضوع ولكن هناك اجتماعات مهمه اليوم
يجتمع الرئيس
زادنتي وسيتحدث عن الدعم الامريكي
والاتزام الامريكي بدعم اوكرانيا
هل يمكن ان نشبه يعني ما يمكن ان يدعم به
او تدعم به اوكرانيا خلال بعد هذه القمه
بانه على
سبيل او مثل
النموذج الاسرائيلي الموجود في المنطقه في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط هل هو اقرب او ابعد من
ذلك
لا اريد المقارنه بين
الان التركي
اليوم سيكون الرئيس بايدن بالقاء كلمه مع
محمد جدا بالنسبه للسياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه سيتحدث عن الدعم الامريكي ودولي
واوكرانيا وايضا سيتحدث عن التحديات
العالميه والقيم الديمقراطيه اكثر من 160
مليار دولار هي حجم المساعدات ربما التي
قدمت من دول حلف الاطلسي لاوكرانيا يعني
منها اكثر من 77 مليار دولار
مقدمه فقط من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل هل الضمانات ستكون ملزمه
فعليا لاي اداره في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه سواء كان الرئيس جمهوريه او
ديمقراطيا
الرساله التي
من الاداره الامريكيه هي اننا
ملتزمين بدعم اوكرانيا مع التاجر امر
وادعم الامريكي الذي
نراه ودعم مشترك بين حزبين
هل هناك احتمالات او يعني نظام يمنع عدم
وجود اي تراجع في حجم هذه المساعدات
العسكريه او الضمانات التي تقدم امريكيه
لاوكرانيا مهما كان الامر
[موسيقى]
كبير من الاداره الامريكيه او من الحزبين
لاوكرانيا
بدعم اوكرانيا مع احتاج الامر ماذا بعد
اعتماد انضمام السويد او ربما توجيه
الدعوه للسويد في
الانضمام لحلف الناتو يعني من خطوات
القادمه فعليا وماذا قدم تركه يعني للرئيس
التركي مقابل موافقه تركيا على البدء في
هذا المشروع
علويات الحكومه الامريكيه في القمه
هي استمرار الاوكرانيه تعزيز قدره الحوث
الرضا
والدفعه وطبعا ايضا انضمام السويد الى
ونحن نرحب تركيا حول
الحرف ونتطلع
التركيب السويد بحيث
قريب
واظن ان هذا
الشيء الملف
مختلف عن ملفات اخرى فيما يتعلق علاقتنا
مع تركيا
مدى بخصوص الصين كيف يتم التعامل ايضا
امريكيا وغربيا ضمن اطار الحلف في مواجهه
او في التعامل مع الصين مستقبلا
ما يتعلق بالسياسه
عامه نحن نسعى منافس مع جمهوريه السينا
الشعبيه
فيما يتعلق بالقنابل العنقوديه هناك جدل
كبير يثار حول امداد
الولايات المتحده بهذه
القنابل المحظوره الدوليه لعده اسباب يعني
كيف سيتم التعامل مع هذا الموت موضوع هذه
التحفظات وهل هل اصبحت امريكا الان مضطره
الى استخدام هذه الاسلحه المحظوره الدوليه
من قبل اكثر من 170 دوله في مواجهه روسيا
الان في الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
هذا
قم
ناحيه الامر الحقيقه هي ان روسيا مستمره
بمحاجمه اوكرانيا بصوره وحشيه بما في ذلك
العنقوديه واوكرانيات تحتاج الى حدثيه
ذخيره شكرا جزيلا لك
من العاصمه الالكتروانيه المتحدثه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه اليزابيث سيتكني
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات